you know how sometimes your your kind of
the geek in class at school and
everybody's always kind of bumping you
around and pushing you around and you
feel kind of dejected alone and and then
when you get into the lab you're just
exploding all over the place just
thriving that's what I do when I'm on
that way
it feels like I'm at home
while you're up there you're super
focused you're focused on your next hand
hold your next foothold everything
shrinks down into this very succinct
little bubble and your only
responsibility is to be able to execute
the next plan maneuvering
and and there's this weird thing that
happens I can't hold on to that airplane
at 160 miles an hour I'm no longer
holding on to the airplane the airplane
is actually holding on to
every time that my life is in danger and
I can't save myself that airplane is
embracing me
I'm stupid in love with that airplane
but the fact is is is my tour playing
I'll be damned if there's another one
like it out there